[Music]
in the 19th century there was virtually
nothing known about how characters or
traits are passed from one generation to
the next
Mendel was really the discoverer of the
process that we now know as genetics so
I've been practicing genetics really for
30 years but what is most beautiful
about the story of Mendel is how he went
about making those discoveries Gregor
Mendel went to university to study
mathematics he then joined an abbey and
began to become very interested in the
question of how the traits get passed
from one generation to the next
Mendel's original idea was to use Bice
but he was forbidden to do this by the
abbot who felt that it was inappropriate
for a monk to be studying what appeared
to be sexual behavior between animals
Mendel then turned around and studied
the sex life of peas they had what we
now realise are purebred strain strains
where no matter how many time you breed
that strain to itself you get the same
plant back and for Mendel this was
incredibly important but the second
reason is that P plans are self
fertilizing the pollen which is the
equivalent of the sperm and the ovule
which is the equivalent of the egg are
basically contained within the head of
the flower and so the only way you get
the pollen inside is it's either self
fertilized or artificially fertilized by
the scientist like Mendel
but it was critically important to his
being able to know with every single
plant who the original parents were of
the
I think Mendel really was a genius he
laid out the scientific method in such a
methodical and rigorous way that I don't
think had ever been done before
particularly in this field that was that
was true genius and then the other was
his ability to interpret his results I
don't think it was obvious and yet he
got it exactly right and we wouldn't
change a thing in his paper even today
no this was the days before the internet
and days before social media and Twitter
you know had Twitter existed in the 19th
century everyone would have known about
Mendel's experiments within a day but
instead it was published and promptly
forgotten so he was only rediscovered
essentially as the giant that he clearly
is well after his death in reading his
paper what I came to appreciate is that
all of the rules that I have learned in
the 20th century about how to go about
designing a good experiment how to
conduct the experiment how to interpret
the results and then how to write them
really clearly so audiences can
appreciate what I've done we're all on
display by Gregor Mendel in the
nineteenth century it is it is perhaps
one of the finest examples I know of a
perfect experiment
you